[Música]
hablamos de un tema que empañan el
rendimiento de los ciclistas colombianos
y los triunfos que han logrado a nivel
internacional nuestros periodistas
deportivos o Rodrigo sedano Juan
putipiales y Leonel pusserrí realizaron
un reportaje revelador de cómo impacta
el dopaje en el ciclismo colombiano la
nación Sudamericana Lamentablemente
tiene el mayor número de ciclistas
sancionados junto a Costa Rica y también
Italia nos acompaña en este espacio
matinal de France 24 Juan pupiales Juan
bienvenido nuevamente acá a nuestra mesa
de trabajo y por supuesto también a
Rodrigo sedano Rodri un gusto que estés
también aquí con nosotros chicos les
quería empezar preguntando Cómo fue esta
realización del reportaje Rodrigo Pues
mira Raúl este reportaje ya era una idea
que venía de largo tiempo aquí en la
redacción de France 24 incluso antes de
que yo empezara a trabajar entonces
llegó un momento que el equipo de
deportes como Juan pupial es mi
compañero y también con Lionel como bien
has indicado nos pusimos a pensar cómo
podíamos empezar a realizar este
reportaje y una de las primeras imágenes
que se ve es en los campeonatos
nacionales de Colombia aquí en Pereira
la ciudad de Pereira allí pudimos ver
pues como la organización nacional
antidopaje también como la la
no me sale ahora perdón como en Colombia
se realizan estos controles antidopajes
como es el trabajo dentro de las propias
competencias porque partíamos de una
base de que Colombia es un país que es
una gran potencia en ciclismo pero a la
vez Tiene un gran número de sancionados
por dopaje igual nuestro compañero Juan
pipiales nos puede contar un poco más sí
comenzó con esa idea de cómo se combate
en Colombia del dopaje también en torno
a lo que hablamos en el reportaje de la
el laboratorio de Bogotá un laboratorio
que desde 2017 no cuenta con las
capacidades no cuenta con la
acreditación para realizar pruebas
antidopaje comenzamos sobre esa idea de
trabajar Bueno Colombia tiene un
programa de dopaje cómo lo está
combatiendo pero sí es cierto que este
reportaje cambia cuando conseguimos ese
testimonio sobre el cual gira el
reportaje a raíz de la información que
nos proporciona esta empezamos a ver que
este tema del dopaje en Colombia va
mucho más allá que ya tiene nombres
tiene caras se tiene vidas personales
tiene tragedias como las que muestra
este esta persona a la que entrevistamos
a raíz de ahí Es verdaderamente cuando
empezamos un poco más a profundizar en
esto porque comenzamos a hacer este
reportaje en los nacionales de ciclismo
como decía Rodríguez que eso Fue en
Febrero y no hemos terminado hasta hace
unas pocas semanas para para acá fue un
poco como todo esto empezó a tomar a
tomar forma hasta hacer un reporteros
porque inicialmente iba a ser una una
nota para el noticiero y finalmente a
raíz de lo que fuimos descubriendo y
terminó siendo de esta manera Juan que
es considerado dopaje que determina que
un deportista está dopado digamos cuando
se hacen este tipo de exámenes hay una
un organismo que se llama la agencia
mundial antidopaje Ellos tienen una
lista que van audiovisualizando año a
año que dice hay una serie de sustancias
que son prohibidas para competir porque
su rendimiento no supone una competencia
limpia no está dentro de la competencia
limpia cuando la agencia mundial
antidopaje dete un ciclista a
consumido algún tipo de esta sustancias
que mejora su rendimiento o que lo
favorece a la hora de competir eso
digamos que a grandes rasgos es lo que
se ha considerado paje Rodrigo qué más
se destaca en este reportaje que puede
encontrar las personas que estén
interesadas en verlo Bueno al hilo de lo
que estábamos hablando de qué es el
dopaje hay algo que hemos querido
destacar que es que esto no es el final
o sea el hay gente que puede haber
cometido un error hay diferentes
circunstancias que pueden haber llevado
a un deportista a ver entrado en el
sistema de dopaje Pero hay una sanción y
después de una sanción puede haber una
segunda oportunidad y creo que es algo
muy importante que nosotros hemos
querido Mostrar es algo que le hemos
dado importancia Dentro de este
reportaje también yo creo que eso parte
de nuestra situación personal porque los
tres somos personas a los que nos
encanta el ciclismo y yo personalmente
competido somos hemos querido hacer este
reportaje como algo que no se vea que
estamos simplemente hablando de lo mal
que se hace las cosas
dentro del ciclismo de Colombia no en
Colombia se hacen cosas muy buenas pero
hay que tener en cuenta que hay esta
cara B pero que tampoco es el final que
hay otra oportunidad y que creo que es
importante haber tenido este testimonio
de este chico que nos Comenta su
situación Porque vemos que dentro de la
situación personal de alguien hay
alguien que ha inducido
él nos habla de su familia no tenía que
llevar comida a su familia entonces el
dopaje no es algo estanco es algo que
está dentro de una situación personal y
situación de Colombia que también es
algo que no sé quizás es un país en el
que es más fácil que en otros y nosotros
queremos demostrar
Que bueno hay que ver que cada parte del
dopaje tiene una situación personal hay
una estructura de dopaje dentro del
ciclismo colombiano Juan por lo que
estoy entendiendo que están diciendo
ahora y que están haciendo las
autoridades para evitar esto no hay un
problema podemos decir tanto como una
estructura es muy difícil llegar a decir
eso tenemos un problema de dopaje en
este país 32 dopados para un país eso no
lo decía el profesor Luis saldarriaga
con el que hablamos eh un técnico muy
reconocido él decía un país que es una
potencia a nivel de ciclismo no puede
tener más de 30 dopados por ciclismo 7
en lo que va de año es una cifra muy
grande lo que podemos decir respecto a
esta a este problema es que cuando
intentamos nosotros conseguir voces que
nos hablaran sobre esto fue muy difícil
fue muy difícil conseguir voces tanto
incluso de la parte oficial como de los
ciclistas entrenadores que nos hablarán
claramente cerca de esto este testimonio
que conseguimos fue muy difícil
conseguirlo de hecho se dan cuenta esa
persona no nos habla a cámara porque
dice que tiene miedo por su vida es algo
que no Debería ser así pero da una
dimensión de que hay algo oscuro en este
mundo que una persona no puede hablar de
su sanción de lo que le pasó por temores
de seguridad es algo que ya te da una
dimensión de qué está pasando en el
ciclismo colombiano pero sí o sea sin
duda Hay que mirarlo de frente hay que
tratarlo Colombia tiene un problema de
dopaje no se pueden hacer pruebas aquí
porque la agencia mundial baja y le
quite toda la acreditación al
laboratorio y es un país que como dice
Rodríguez hay que destacar lo hace cosas
muy muy buenas pero que esta cara
también hay que demostrarla claro
Rodrigo además de lo que decía Juan de
consecuencias en cuanto a la seguridad
de esta persona el el protagonista de su
reportaje que otras consecuencias hay
para los deportistas que se dopan no
si yo más que para los deportistas que
se dopan que también por supuesto yo
diría para los deportistas que no se
dopan es una falta de credibilidad para
la gente que juega limpio que hay que
recalcar que yo creo que es la mayoría
es un problema muy serio Porque Colombia
ha sido es Y probablemente seguirá
siendo una potencia mundial en el
ciclismo también lo decíamos al inicio
de este reportaje en la presentación
Colombia es junto a Reino Unido junto a
España y si no me confundo mal junto a
Italia verdad el único país que desde
2016 ha conseguido ganar Las tres
grandes vueltas del ciclismo eso es algo
muy importante algo que pocos países en
el mundo han conseguido y más que para
las consecuencias de los que se dopan
que también son muy importantes Hay
personas a las que esto les trunca toda
una carrera vital a un tiempo en el que
han invertido mucho esfuerzo para llegar
a ser ciclistas el problema no es solo
ese sino para los que juegan limpio Juan
para las personas que nos ven en este
momento y que también ver en nuestras
plataformas digitales Hay algún tipo de
correo electrónico para denuncias unas
las personas que se quieran comunicar
con ustedes exactamente derrado como te
comentaba ha sido muy difícil conseguir
cosas que nos hablan acerca de lo que
está pasando con el dopaje en Colombia
nosotros por eso Hemos establecido un
correo electrónico que es del dominio de
protón punto m un dominio que garantiza
mucha seguridad mucha privacidad para
todo ese tipo de denuncias que nos
puedan llegar es el correo de France 24
es arroba protón punto mme Ahí estamos
recibiendo denuncias para continuar con
esta investigación con la como le
decimos es una investigación larga y
creemos que apenas estamos viviendo una
primera parte un primer acercamiento a
lo que está pasando en Colombia queremos
ver qué otro tipo de denuncias puede
haber como la que nos cuenta Esta
persona el protagonista de nuestro
reportaje